In the same way that Kylo Ren's ultra-high-waisted
pants will never catch on as the next hot
fashion trend, it's an undeniable fact that
not everyone loved Star Wars: The Last Jedi.
When the film launched in theaters in December
2017, audiences were more divided than Darth
Maul.
Now, as we're nearing the one-year anniversary
of the Rian Johnson-directed flick, an old
complaint about The Last Jedi has resurfaced.
But it's not just any old gripe - it's one
that regards a plot hole that one YouTuber
claims, quote, "broke Star Wars forever."
The scene in question is the one in which
Vice Admiral Amilyn Holdo does something no
character has ever even attempted to do in
the history of Star Wars: she kicks General
Leia Organa's ship into lightspeed and proceeds
to drive it directly into Supreme Leader Snoke's
ship, the Mega-class Star Dreadnought that
served as the First Order's mobile headquarters.
Holdo's move allowed the Rebel Alliance members
aboard the Raddus a narrow window of time
to escape on the lifeboats before the First
Order could track the Raddus through hyperspace.
Before this moment in The Last Jedi, fans
had never seen a Star Wars character carry
out a kamikaze attack.
Once they did, well, it got the gears in their
brains turning.
Some franchise loyals, like YouTuber Thor
Skywalker, feel that the scene ripped a hole
in more than than the Supremacy - it opened
up a plot hole in the entire Star Wars universe.
Thor Skywalker argues that if Holdo could
damage the Supremacy by jumping to lightspeed
and crashing into it, the Rebels could have
done the exact same thing to the Death Star
in A New Hope.
He further claims that the so-called "Holdo
Maneuver" renders the Rebel Alliance's attack
on the Death Star somewhat ineffective, since
they could have easily created a battle station
that could implement the same tactic Holdo
used, one that also has, quote, "the ability
to send or launch massive objects into hyperspace
at planets or whatever else it might want
to destroy."
In his argument, he stated:
"Why doesn't Holdo just put some droids on
some transport ships and have them jumping
into hyperspace at the First Order fleet?
She apparently knew such an action would work
so it doesn't make sense why she waited so
long to employ it.
You can then go back to any battle in Star
Wars history and wonder why the Holdo Maneuver
wasn't used.
[...] [The Last Jedi] seems to be the most
reckless in terms of what it lets into the
canon.
It pulled apart, or broke, the rest of Star
Wars by introducing things that makes us question
everything that comes before it."
We can certainly see where these arguments
are coming from.
In A New Hope, the Rebels probably could have
done what Holdo did in The Last Jedi.
But would it have made the movie better?
Nope!
"Then man your ships, and may the force be
with you.”
“Yay!”
While Holdo's attack does signify a bit of
a logic question in the Star Wars universe,
to call it a franchise-breaking plot hole
is a little much.
To some fans, the "Holdo Maneuver" truly has
put an irreversible dent in the series.
To others, it's not that big of a deal.
As far as director Rian Johnson is concerned,
the moment was actually inspired by the original
trilogy.
He explained to the Empire Film Podcast:
"Ever since Han is talking about how if you
don't get the calculations right you could
go through, you know, I've always wanted to
see what that would look like."
Conflicting opinions about whether or not
The Last Jedi broke Star Wars aside, writer-director
J.J. Abrams could still keep the franchise
afloat with Episode IX, set for release on
December 20, 2019.
So what do you think?
Did the Holdo maneuver "break" Star Wars for
you?
Let us know in the comments!